well the mortgage I mean I I think no I
you mean do I get up in the morning and
think wow I see the the end of that
rainbow and there's some something
telling me write the great American
story about parking no no I don't have
that well it's hard for me because I I
do different kinds of writing and and so
I mean they're they're non fiction
writers I mean the one who's always been
sort of my hero is Joseph Mitchell who
was a New Yorker writer for many years
who died on seven or eight years ago I
guess on who I admired partly his is
just his craft I mean what he what he
was able to do and you know I don't
write the way he writes but so it's not
a stylistic thing but I was always
amazed that he was able to get the marks
of riding off of what he did and also he
approached people to head on and without
without any sort of condescension or
certainly without any fawning I mean he
didn't write about the people that some
reporters fought on her I mean he wrote
about you know often people on the
waterfront or and the fleabag hotels or
something like that but he was a the
stuff was wonderful and and I I think as
far as humor goes one writer who's now
sort of half forgotten who I always
admired a lot was Peter to freeze his
novels again I don't write the way he
writes I mean he had a lot of work plays
and puns and
and things but he and I think there are
a lot of good humorous writers now who
write short pieces that are funny and
often wise which is remarkable when you
think of of how many other avenues there
are for somebody who's funny I mean the
you know the sort of legendary now that
the the bright kid from the Harvard
Lampoon doesn't come to the New Yorker
now it goes to Hollywood and write
sitcoms or something so our television
or movies so considering how many other
outlets there are most of which pay a
lot better than writing for a magazine
or a newspaper or even books it's it's
remarkable how many good ones there are
you